it's time for Medicare enrollment we
have these volunteers standing by to
take your questions
regarding Medicare eligibility you can
give them a call at the phone number on
your screen meantime we have Dr moyad
Ismail here with us from Southwest
Medical thanks for being here first of
all what type of services do you have at
Southwest thanks for having me so we've
been servicing our community for over 50
years we're part of the Optum Care
Network we have over 350 physicians in
our Network and providers we have
multiple Specialties within the Optum
Care Network we are located in about 25
Plus locations whether it's from urgent
cares specialty clinics Adult Medicine
Peds all that so we also offer as part
of the Medicare Advantage plan you can
get access to 24 7
visits whether it's through an urgent
care or through a now clinic which is a
virtual portal we also have telephonic
advice nurse you can reach out to them
24 seven whenever you have any concerns
tremendous Services thank you so much
for being here and being part of this
give the phone number on your screen a
call if you have any questions about
Medicare eligibility and we will be
right back
[Music]
I'm Kendall Tenney in the call 8 phone
bank tonight the volunteers here are
answering your questions about Medicare
eligibility numbers on your screen
702-650-110